BALTZ: I recently discovered
something disturbing
while reviewing my favorite
men's rights subreddit.
There's a witch hunt
against men in Silicon Valley.
Some men are even saying
that the feminists have
"formed a cabal whose goal was
to subjugate men."
for their so-called
sexist behavior.
GAYLE KING:
Silicon Valley has been battling
allegations of mistreatment
and sexual harassment
of women in the workplace.
The memo, which was published
in a few different publications,
has sparked outrage
here in Silicon Valley.
That the lack of women working
in tech is attributable
to biological differences.
Within days, Damore was fired.
BALTZ: Some people are asking
if men are the real victims
in the tech industry,
and I say yes.
I decided to make it my mission
to give the oppressed men
of Silicon Valley a voice,
so I reached out
to a ton of men,
but they all said no,
probably
because they were too scared
to come forward
with their stories.
That's when I finally found
someone brave enough--
Keith Mann.
Keith had created
a successful e-commerce site
called "Witchsy."
So I went to go meet him
in his home office
in Los Angeles
to hear the full story.
Hi.
-Hi. -I'm Penelope.
-I'm Tim.
-Hi. I'm Kate.
-Nice to meet you.
-Nice to meet you, too.
Uh, I am here to see your boss,
Keith Mann.
Keith's not real.
(Baltz laughs)
-Okay, can I come inside?
-Yeah, come inside.
-Yeah.
-All right, great.
Uh, Keith?
These jokesters who were
pretending Keith isn't real
are Penelope Gazin
and Kate Dwyer,
the founders of Witchsy,
an e-commerce site
that specializes in weird art
that I don't get,
and frankly,
find pretty disgusting.
So explain to me how you think
Keith Mann saved your business.
-We just...
-Well, we-we created him.
Yeah. He's not real.
I pretended
to be Keith on e-mails.
-Uh... -I made the e-mail
"KeithMannWitchsy@gmail."
Because he was too busy
to create the e-mail himself.
Again,
he's not a real person, so...
BALTZ: You got to be frickin'
(bleep) me, ladies.
Why would anybody
make up a fake man?
GAZIN:
We fabricated him
because we needed a buffer
when e-mailing
with coders and developers.
Every time we would communicate
or e-mail
with a specific developer,
he would never address us
by name,
but Kate noticed that whenever
she would use Keith's e-mail
to contact him, he always start
every e-mail with, "Keith."
There were just quicker
responses, more yeses,
less excuses every time
that we used the Keith e-mail.
We developed
the character of Keith.
Like he, you know, has a wife.
-We created the Twitter account
for him. -Yeah.
-Jokes about Mondays.
-(Baltz laughs)
They're the hardest day
of the week.
Oh, my God,
Mondays (bleep) suck.
Keith actually was a tool
for us.
We felt
we had to prove ourselves
before we were given respect,
whereas with Keith, he was just
automatically given it.
Is this something
that you would ever do again?
Yeah, I would.
God!
(bleep)
Now I was pissed.
By giving a job to a fake man,
Penelope and Kate
were taking a job away
from a real man.
That was sexism
at its most despicable.
After all,
executives in Silicon Valley
are only 89% men.
That's not even
in the nineties.
So it was time to meet
with some real men from tech
and have a bro fest
to get to the bottom of this.
But once again,
no men would meet with me.
So I had to meet with a bunch
of women instead.
Yikes.
These man haters are all
Silicon Valley pros
who have worked for companies
like GoPro, Apple and reddit.
I just feel like
right now there is a witch hunt
out there for men
lead by feminist bullies,
and it's super uncomfortable.
It's not a witch hunt.
So we conducted a study
with over 200 women,
uh, learning more
about their experiences
with sexual harassment.
They were saying that, "I don't
want to pursue a legal route.
"I don't want settlements,
I don't need money.
"All I want is for my company
to resolve this issue
and for it to not happen again."
We need a culture
where we respect everyone.
-Please stop ganging up on me.
-We're trying
to tell you how we feel
and how things can improve.
Well,
it's not comfortable for me.
Mm-hmm.
She didn't give a rotten dump
about men's feelings.
These women were too focused
on their own problems--
like the fact that
only five percent of start-ups
are run by women.
But what about men?
What... about... men?
Do men have a safe space
to network without women?
I mean, this seems
like a huge issue now.
Anywhere and everywhere you go
is a safe space for you.
I don't feel safe right now.
Ooh. That actually gives me
a really great idea.
I wanted to pitch my great idea
directly to a man--
but surprise, surprise,
the men were too afraid
to meet with me.
So I found Ari Horie--
she's the CEO and founder
of Women's Startup Lab,
as featured in Forbes.
And I'm a confident man who has
a great feeling about this.
You're probably familiar
with the website LinkedIn.
But I'm going
to change the game.
LinkedMen.
Men do not have
a safe space in tech.
LinkedMen aims to make tech
a safe space for men once again.
-LinkedMen...
(deep, distorted):
LinkedMen.
It's a stupid idea.
This is not
a charitable organization.
We believe in investing in a
company that has a viable idea.
Unbelievable.
I guess it was time to go
to one of the few places left
that are still safe for men,
a sports bar...
or a strip club...
or congress or the White House,
or any boardroom, or the world
of online video games,
or Hollywood, or that
sports theme haircutting place
I've been dying to try out,
or the South in general,
or the North, also the Midwest,
or airplane cockpits,
or a Limp Bizkit concert.
The world is closing in
on us, fellas.
Take refuge where you can.